ウズ準備完了だう
プロローグ
ポン日は肇社長ですちょっとて全然証拠がするんですけどもういいや本屋
猛威俺もこの哲也のテンション的な質問方だすることを決めたから今回もたくさんの質
もありがとう同じ感謝とで広い早速今回は走行ないってみまー書を書いてどうぞや
拾ってくださいやない理由が入ってくださいやだよなんでそんな気の中で聞いている
ef
ヤバってもうおかしいなんでなんで好みだけど入ってもする理由なんてを買って本題
ゲーム入ってもすぐ後ぞ
元にくくや細すぎだがそんなんで女の子守れるのかもし女の子とデートしている突然白
伸びてが凍結したらどうするんだ
女効果があって走るのか試しの所沢でやって皆さん年告げ恥ずかしいだらコレ
付いた方博物館バーさーてみーご博物館どこからまま
ん
バーン
ビルガー
指バーンペルダウン
yumiko ん
指かーっ
jr ん
ベリフォンリーダーさーん
えっを a なんやこれああ
どうせ採用されないやろどうせ採用されないんだろうなぁもうこんなにコメントがもう
を食べたああああ
81コメント
はあああああ
ブーブー ec 1にござる
に服着ないよそれは一理あるな
ハノハノん
とは別途そのそのすっ
好き月焼き食べたいおいハゲ意外と動画もすごいじゃないか
あっはぁ
ありがとうございますご意向も頑張るは5校で真似してもやしでも音は
ありがとう僕の神で食べる身をはじめがお前中身だけなんで食べるわけねーだろウスは
僕のだったらいいをなぜなら金コミュニティだからねやったぜ食ってやる
僕もう9分車ましたかつ立つはず幾分に関係で aging beauty にしてる
はずがねえな
やっぱはじめ c 神ですよ味の保証をするから信号を全部お前じゃねえか9
十年後の日本人の真似してください気だろニコニコああああ
2つの中で前後だっスプーンと遊ぶに乗ってめっちゃ官女
はい
止めたいなぁこれでも走れ
小さくバッターへ茹でたらいいから乗って食いが良い
板壁をしてカメラ右手
大便が好きなさん寿るいだからお前に大便横それは本当に心配だ
大丈夫かおいはじめ受験シーズンなっていうのに初めから出す動画ずっと見てたら
航空があったじゃねーかバカヤロありがとうございますおめでとう
おめでとラオネエこれでと君はガーナはボスだけじゃないね
おめでとうがのコメントにいるみんなも君を張ってくるダークです井上嵩てください
版が目を覚ますか俺事始め忘れない場所にいた
ここは
たい所なんだ俺のつぶやきに講ずるように頭の中で聞き覚えのある声を響いた
始め助けてこっ
この声はところ増加
どこぞどこにいるんだまマリオ見えませがそこには誰もいない
しかし俺の頭の中ではとブラザーの夜鷲声が聞こえ始めんと助けて
遠くに c だめだ母校がー
ダーグン c ぬーべが
先生フレッどうぞところぞ
天井白ところ座の声は突然聞こえなくなっ
なが分かったことが一つそれはきっと所沢ダークにせいの上に襲われているかっ個性的
なとの違いない
そしてこの状況についてもおそらくダークね線動画が何か絡んでいるということ
この声はまたもや俺の頭の中に声が響いた
しかしその声はあのあくまでこうやっ
久しぶりだなあはじめだ
ダーク嬉しいの上
お前
所沢どこに俺がチークとなぁペレス犬親と杖はないでしたーー
プーばくまくまくまくまくまくまなんだこいつキモ2類
5までとこローザに会いたいならこれから私がいうところに来るがいい
俺はどこに行けばいい
うんあそれならもう大丈夫みたいななんだと
俺にはダークにそうな野外っていうことも意味がさっぱりわからなかった奴の言葉に
困惑していると
はじめ北はここだよ
所沢の声過疎
俺はすぐさま後ろに振り返りはじめが助けてくれないから
僕汚されちゃった
全部はじめの生はじめ責任取る
僕はじめを食べると
ところだ
マッハ
履いて外でいかがだったでしょうか質問コーナーもうもう質問コーナーではありません
ね初めて阿蘇ボードコーナーですね
いやけど本当にファンの皆さんが入って初めて完成する動画なのでめちゃくちゃなこと
が多かったんですけどとても楽しかったで採用されなかった皆様またコメントをぜひし
てくださいねまた次回の動画でお会いしましょう
じゃん